the media has spent the last week trying
to convince america that thanksgiving is
a celebration rooted in evil
pilgrims did not bring turkey sweet
potato pie or cranberries to
thanksgiving instead of bringing
stuffing and biscuits those settlers
brought genocide and violence that
genocide and violence is still on the
menu
well at my house we might have some pie
in the menu but certainly not genocide
and not to be outdone newspapers rushed
to join the hate
with the philadelphia tribune saying
celebrating thanksgiving is celebrating
racist genocide and usa today framing
thanksgiving as day of mourning for
indigenous people
but this revisionist history is just
wrong the pilgrims were friends with
their hosts and thankful for their help
as writer rich lowry points out saying
quote
the peace with the wampanoag lasted
about 50 years it's a mistake to read
future conflicts back into the 1621
feast a moment of hopefulness
so tomorrow is a day about coming
together to celebrate our family our
freedoms and the fact that we live in
the greatest country on earth
and maybe nothing sums it up more than
these powerful words from one of
america's great thinkers linus from the
peanuts
the year 1621 the pilgrims held their
first thanksgiving feast they invited
the great indian chief messel soy who
brought 90 of his brave indians in a
great abundance of food elder william
brewster who was a minister said a
prayer that went something like this
we thank god for our homes and our food
and our safety in a new land we thank
god for the opportunity to create a new
world for freedom and justice
and that is what this holiday is about
thanking god for everything we have in
this beautiful country well that in a
little bit of football
but it's certainly not about trying to
trash those people who built this great
nation
so here to respond for a little bit of
optimism is the governor of south dakota
and my friend uh christie gnomes so
governor listen give me give me some
optimism what are you celebrating and
what are the people in south dakota
celebrating and thankful for as you come
into thanksgiving tomorrow
well first of all sean thank you for
covering the true history of this
holiday it's an incredibly special
holiday for all of us here in south
dakota and across the country and you
telling the story of what really
happened
back then is incredibly important
because i've learned that throughout the
years we have to continue to educate the
next generation on what the real history
is and what a true history is and the
fact that those native americans far
outnumbered those pilgrims at plymouth
and they brought the food to them and
helped take care of them and they
celebrated and we're grateful together i
think is an incredibly important message
for this country today listen in south
dakota we're still harvesting we have
some folks that are still bringing food
in from the fields so we're incredibly
grateful for safety and the good weather
that we've had a lot of people are
hunting out
hunting deer and pheasants in the
morning and then we're all going to sit
around our tables and celebrate our
families and be glad that god has
blessed south dakota in incredible ways
you talked about a lot of other states
that are tearing down statues south
dakota's putting them up in fact we're
taking the four presidents that are on
mount rushmore we're building statues to
them and putting them on our capital
rotunda
so that we can send a message to the
rest of the world that we're proud of
our leaders we know they were flawed but
they led us through challenging times
and that we're going to stand behind our
true and honest history you know
governor it is great to have awesome
governors who uh defend history but as i
talked about in this uh lead up to
bringing you on there is a concern
because the left is canceling two of the
faces on mount rushmore any concerns
about the left coming for mount rushmore
in south dakota
well there was a lot of threats
especially when president trump visited
july 3 of 2020.
in fact we had to put security folks out
there and they partnered very well with
secret service and with other law
enforcement officers to keep it safe it
was amazing to me the threats that were
coming against mount rushmore several
people were threatening to blow it up
several were threatening to pour red
paint down the faces and stain it
forever
and we had to expend resources as a
state to protect that national monument
so you know the real
hate in this country i think for our
history we have to recognize has been
around for a very long time although
it's not been something that so many
people in the country have been aware of
and that we've realized has taken place
and is continuing to take place in so
many parts of this country you know and
to that point governor we see that now
more than ever right the left the left
is attacking history they're attacked
attacking thanksgiving so i guess the
question for you is you know how do we
actually defend it you know what do we
have to do as americans leaders like you
as governors or parents how do we defend
history and thanksgiving to make sure we
preserve it for future generations now
you tell the history and you educate
people use every opportunity you have to
be in front of a group to share the true
history of what happened
that's one of the reasons why when we're
focusing on our k-12 curriculum is
making sure that we're going to have
children read the declaration of
independence we're going to have them
read the history of thanksgiving and
what really happens so that we can't
have people twist it and make lies out
of it and use it for an agenda that they
want to fundamentally change this
country so our foundation
was built on people seeking freedom they
came here for freedom from tyranny and
wanted a democracy and a republic where
they could make choices for themselves
and those pilgrims at plymouth learned
that through their partnership and their
work with the native americans that they
could
have success in this country after very
difficult times and they did so and
that's why we're all here today
you know governor i'm so grateful for
your leadership all you've done in south
dakota um thank you and i appreciate
your friendship and have a great
thanksgiving with your family well you
tell rachel and the kids happy
thanksgiving from the gnome family we
miss them and we're grateful for your
friendship and to brian as well hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else